الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله التي شهدت
في الساعات الاخيره تصعيدا في الاقتحامات
والاعتقالات في صفوف الفلسطينيين فقد اصب
شعبان فلسطيني خلال مواجهات بين مجموعات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اسرق اقتحامها بدله قباطيه
جنوب جنين في الضفه الغربيه فجر اليوم
واعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسيره المحرر
محمود نزال من منزل عائلته في البلده
وفي مخيم قلنديا في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
ذكر ناشطون فلسطينيون ان قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقتحمت احياء المخيم في
الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم واعتقلت
عددا من الشبان قبل ان تنسحب من المخيم
الواقع شمال القدس المحتله ومن جانبها فدى
نادي الاسير الفلسطينيه ان قوات الاحتلال
اعتقلت فجر اليوم تسعه فلسطينيين في حملات
دهم في الضفه الغربيه شملت جنين ونابلس
ورام الله والبيره والخليل وطولكرم
وقلقيليه